on parle beaucoup de la crise climatique
mais on vit aussi en parallèle une crise
de la biodiversité un peu partout sur la
planète des espèces disparaissent à un
rythme alarmant pour sauvegarder cette
biodiversité la de plus en plus de
citoyens réclament que l'on protège de
toute urgence certains écosystèmes
fragiles
mais la tâche est loin d'être facile
surtout quand des intérêts économiques
sont en jeu voici notre grand dossier
sur les aires protégées
outaouais printemps 2021
robert naiman pour salah les bonnes
vieilles fournier mais pas vue de
l'amener
à tout va ne pourra mener
[Musique]
ce matin le consultant en botanique
patrick gravel et la biologiste
marie-ève roy se dirige vers une des
rares forêts anciennes toujours intacte
du sud du québec
depuis des années elle étudie la flore
et la faune de ce territoire de près de
35 kilomètres carrés situé sur des
terres publiques un lieu nommé mach
kitty par les premières nations
m'a choqué c'est un mot anishnabe
algonquin qui signifie ramade
c'est un lieu de guérison que ça veut
dire guérison dans notre relation avec
la terre
compte tenu du caractère unique de cet
écosystème
chercheurs membres de la communauté
anishinabe
citoyens et élus de la région réclament
que ce territoire soit désigné comme
aire protégée
magique et c'est un site qui est
important à l'échelle de l'amérique du
nord ces piscines parmi nos terres
publiques les plus au sud de la province
donc les plus bio de versier territoire
qui est qui qui est exceptionnel qui est
unique
aujourd'hui patrick et marie ève pénètre
au coeur de la vieille forêt une eva
billère où l'on trouve des arbres âgés
de deux cents à trois cents ans c'est
très très particulier parquet ce genre
de foire et là on les voit plus on en
trouve très rarement le des forêts où il
ya pas de camions qui ont pas raté ya
pas une machinerie
plusieurs espèces végétales et animales
à statut précaire peuple ce territoire
on y retrouve la grenouille démarrait la
couleuvre à collier le faucon pèlerin et
aussi la paruline assuré un des oiseaux
les plus rares au québec
la carte celle de plantes or est très
très très impressionnante et si un match
qui affirme c'est peut-être une des plus
élevées donc on conserve des plans le
préhistorique ici dans des vieilles
forêts en conserve des oiseaux corps
trouvera pas ailleurs qu' on est aussi
capable de séquestrer du carbone
beaucoup beaucoup dans le seul par
toutes les symbioses qui ont qu'il ya
entre les arbres et les champignons par
exemple avec ça c'est une très grande
valeur
[Musique]
sylvain de la grange enseigne à
l'institut des sciences de la forêt
tempérée de l'université du québec en
outaouais il s'intéresse aux services
que les écosystèmes forestiers rendre
aux humains comme c'est le cas ici à
mach qui quitte ce territoire là il faut
comprendre que c'est un territoire
intacte un territoire qui qui encore ses
fonctions et ses interactions entre tous
ces organismes qui sont naturels donc ça
c'est ça une grande valeur c'est un
territoire qui rend aussi beaucoup de
services écosystémiques donc qui régule
l'eau de pluie qui va filtrer l'air qui
va aussi abriter les animaux une
biodiversité qui va être un peu
exceptionnel
ces services écosystémiques comprennent
aussi la préservation de la culture la
chasse la pêche et la randonnée par
exemple ce qui n'est pas négligeable en
ces temps de pandémie
un accès à ce territoire là c'est un
accès à un territoire on peut être en
santé où on peut se ressourcer je pense
que l'aco vide nous a démontré à quel
point on avait besoin d'avoir accès à la
nature c'est un des grands services que
rendre les écosystèmes
[Musique]
pour désigner ce qui est une aire
protégée le canada et le québec se sont
inspirés de la définition proposée par
l'union internationale pour la
conservation de la nature
une aire protégée c'est un espace
géographique bien défini qui est gérée
de façon à y assurer à long terme la
conservation de la nature des services
écosystémiques et des valeurs
culturelles qui sont attachés
au delà de la conservation les états
doivent s'assurer que la biodiversité
qu'il protège soit représentative des
espèces animales et végétales qui se
retrouve sur l'ensemble de leur
territoire
il leur faut aussi privilégier la mise
en place de corridors écologiques afin
de faciliter la libre circulation des
espèces
faux pas qui a et rod espaçant deux
forêts naturelles faut qu'il y en ait
qui soit qui permettent aux animaux de
se déplacer et de se rendre à l'autre
donc si le trou est trop gras ils vont
pas nécessairement traversée piratés
[Musique]
la majorité de la biodiversité du québec
se trouve au sud du 49e parallèle
c'est aussi là que les milieux naturels
sont le plus soumis à la pression de
l'homme dans ce contexte un nombre
grandissant de citoyens exigent la
création de nouvelles aires protégées
sur cette partie sensible du territoire
dans le sud du québec il ya très peu de
territoires qui n'ont pas encore été
trop aménagé et donc ils deviennent très
très très très important en terme de
représentation de la biodiversité
original est un projet qui est atteinte
eu depuis longtemps en décembre 2020 le
ministre de l'environnement a annoncé
avoir réussi à protéger près de 17% des
territoires terrestres et d'eau douce de
la province en apparence cette bonne
nouvelle
permettait au québec d'atteindre les
objectifs internationaux qui s'était
engagé à respecter
mais en y regardant de plus près on se
rend compte que la majorité des
nouvelles aires protégées n'était pas
située au sud mais plutôt au nord du 49e
parallèle
si on dit que la biodiversité se
concentrent dans le sud du québec puis 1
entente internationale qui dit on doit
protéger la biodiversité
mais si on protège seulement au nord est
ce qu'on est en train de vraiment honoré
ça je pense que les gens allument piste
disait je pense que ça pas de bon sens
cette décision là
[Musique]
ce qui choque les citoyens c'est qu'au
moment d'annoncer l'atteinte de sa cible
de 17 % québec avait entre les mains
plus de 80 projets d'aires protégées
dont les trois quarts étaient situés
dans le sud du québec
après des années d'études et de
consultation ces dossiers faisait pour
la plupart consensus dans leur
communauté
mais tous ces projets ont été rejetés à
la dernière minute même celui de mach
kitty qui avait pourtant reçu l'aval du
ministère de l'environnement au début je
croyais pas vraiment s'il m'avait dit
c'est sûr que ça peut pas virer de bord
fait que c'était comme j'étais incrédule
traque allemand ça s'est transformé en
colère on se fait dire c'est ça qui est
ça on a mis douze années de travail de
notre vie ben cotton est coiffeur chez
quelqu'un
la création de nouvelles aires protégées
va soustraire des territoires à la coupe
forestière et ceux qui militent pour une
plus grande protection des écosystèmes
crois que ce sont les intérêts de cette
industrie qui aurait dicté les choix du
gouvernement
j'explique ça peut-être par une une
vision qui datent pas d'aujourd'hui
c'est une vision assez assez vieilles de
de garder le maximum de territoires dans
la possibilité forestière proche des
usines dans le sud
[Musique]
malgré tout ce qui porte le projet
d'aires protégées de match qui qui garde
espoir
le premier ministre l'a dit on va
travailler fort avec la pandémie pour
aider nos aînés moi j'entends les
enfants que ça qui s'inquiètent pour
leurs futurs jeudi on devrait travailler
aussi fort pour offrir un avenir à nos
l'air protéger magique et qu'ils ont on
veut la voir on va la voir parce que
c'est un territoire exceptionnel c'est
un petit bijou donc oui on va la voir
parce que c'est c'est la chose à faire
protéger ce territoire là
la pression populaire était forte et le
vent a tourné
quelques mois après notre passage en
outaouais le gouvernement du québec a
finalement mis en réserve le territoire
de match qui qui avec l'intention d'y
créer une nouvelle aire protégée
récemment quelques territoires situés au
sud du 49e parallèle se sont aussi
ajoutés à la liste mais des dizaines
d'autres projets d'aires protégées reste
toujours en attente